si los servicios de emergencia trabajan
a contrarreloj porque todavía queda
gente atrapada en vehículos o en sus
propios hogares para que os hagáis una
idea solamente en el condado de
westchester al norte del estado de nueva
york en las últimas horas se ha
rescatado a 100 personas que se habían
quedado encerradas en sus casas o en sus
vehículos debido a las inundaciones una
labor nada fácil porque todavía hay
carreteras y calles sobre todo
carreteras principales que están
completamente anegadas por el agua y
están cortadas por lo que moverse por
ellas no está siendo nada fácil los
socorristas y equipos de emergencia lo
están haciendo encima de barcas van casa
por casa tratando de ver si alguien más
se ha quedado atrapado en estos momentos
hay más de 200.000 personas sin
suministro eléctrico en el área tri
estatal es decir pensilvania nueva
yersey y nueva york y aquí en nueva york
en la ciudad no mayor en la gran manzana
anoche se cancelaron todas las líneas de
metro y esta mañana poco a poco se han
ido restableciendo pero de manera muy
lenta muchas personas han pasado toda la
noche en las estaciones de metro porque
se quedaron allí atrapadas cuando
comenzaron las fuertes lluvias y las
inundaciones el aeropuerto de nueva york
que ayer canceló sus vuelos porque
también quedó completamente anegado por
el agua poco a poco se va restableciendo
pero como digo de manera muy lenta
porque los destrozos son muy grandes el
presidente de los eeuu joe biden ya ha
ofrecido al área tri-estatal la ayuda
federal para ayudar para apoyar en esas
tareas de recuperación algo que no va a
ser nada fácil porque aquí llueve sobre
mojado hace dos semanas que teníamos la
tormenta henri y para que os hagáis una
idea del servicio de meteorología es la
primera vez en la historia de esta
ciudad que emite una alerta por
inundaciones repentinas y es que en tan
solo una hora llegaron a caer 80 litros
de agua